Let's take a quick look at how to create
custom Compute Engine instances.
Open your Google Cloud dashboard and go to
the Compute Engine section.
Now click create instance. Here, you can see the
customized link you can customize the
number of CPU cores as well as the
gigabytes of memory for your instance
once you've selected all the appropriate
options scroll down and click create.
in a few seconds your custom VM should be
created
you can also create a custom VM using
the gcloud tool.
Run 'gcloud compute instances create' then give it the name of your new instance, and now you can use
the --custom-cpu flag followed
by the number of CPU course and the
--custom-memory flag followed by the
gigabytes of memory. In a few seconds you
can see your new VM!